think people are going to Rally around
president Trump we know that our
elections are corrupt here they've been
corrupt for a long time 2020. we saw
what happened when we ignored a corrupt
election and allowed someone like Joe
Biden to get into the White House and
Lead our country into destruction and
I'm just like you can you can look down
the camera and say that but you know
that's not true you know that the
election was not stolen I wouldn't
expect you coming from Australia to know
one day you're from the UK country oh
you're from the UK I was told you're
from Australia so you'd speak to someone
who is on the right of politics but not
not to an independent General expect you
to understand what's happening in our
country because I can see you've come at
this from a left agenda which is very
typical of the fake news and the people
aren't listening to you they really
aren't and you don't understand what it
means to shed blood for your freedom
like we did here when we broke ourselves
free from a tyrant called King George so
when you learn a little bit about our
history then I'll have a conversation
but you don't know what the hell you're
talking about